منذ حوالي عام كانت هناك تلك
المظاهرات في جميع أنحاء إيران أه التي
تسببت في قدر كبير من الصراع الداخلي،
غالبًا ما تحب الحكومة الإيرانية أن
تقول إن هذا كان احتجاجًا صغيرًا ولكن إذا كنت
تعفو عن 22 ألفًا وما زلت تسجن
الكثيرين أكثر أه
تشير إلى أن هذه الأمور كانت كبيرة، وما أريد أن
أسألك عنه هو جوهر هذه
القضية المتعلقة بالحجاب حول ما إذا كان يجب على النساء
تغطية رؤوسهن، وقد نشأت كمسلمة في
الهند، وسافرت في جميع أنحاء العالم الإسلامي.
مئات الملايين من المسلمين لا
يعتقدون أن هذا شيء
يجب أن يُطلب من النساء القيام به، هناك
العشرات من الدول الإسلامية حيث
حكوماتها متدينة للغاية وتؤمن
بالإسلام ومخلصة
ولا تصدق ذلك، فهي تعتقد أنه
يجب على المرأة أن تفعل ذلك.  الخيار والحق
في ارتداء ما يريدون وليس لديهم
نظام أبوي أخبرهم بما يجب عليهم
فعله هل كل هؤلاء مئات الملايين
ربما أكثر من مليار مسلم مخطئون
وجمهورية إيران الإسلامية وحدها على
حق
فيما حدث خلال النهار
تحدث عنه  في وقت سابق كان وجود
عدد قليل من الناس
في
إيران لم يدعم الشعب بأي
شكل من الأشكال أولئك الذين قاموا بأعمال شغب في شوارع
إيران،
قلة دعم الناس
أحبطت خططهم، كان هناك البعض الذين
تم خداعهم وكان هناك آخرون  الذين
ارتكبوا جرائم قتل ارتكبوا جرائم خطيرة
لكن ما حدث العام الماضي كان حربا
إعلامية يديرها العدو
ولا أريد أن أذكر شبكات تلفزيونية أو
شبكات إخبارية بل شبكات
مقرها الرئيسي في الدول الأوروبية الثلاث
في الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية الذين  بث الأخبار على مدار 24 ساعة في
اليوم، يقومون بتدريس تكتيكات الإرهاب بشكل علني،
لذلك يقومون بخطوات تعليمية حول
كيفية
صنع كوكتيل مولوتوف،
وهذا هو أحد جوانب عداء
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية تجاه
جمهورية إيران الإسلامية بالإضافة إلى وجه
معين.  الدول الأوروبية
تجاه إيران ليس الحجاب هو ما يهمهم
ليس غطاء الرأس هو ما يهمهم
ليس
حقوق المرأة ليس القضايا النووية ليس
حقوق الإنسان لأن هناك دول
مثل النظام الصهيوني أه
النظام الصهيوني مسلح حتى الأسنان
أو لا، لماذا لا يخرج صوت واحد
من الولايات المتحدة احتجاجا، لماذا
لا يخرج صوت من أي من
الدول الأوروبية ويحتج اليوم ولكن
الحجاب يهم المرأة الإيرانية لقد
تحدثت معهم لقد تحدثت  إذا كانوا في طهران، فإن الأمر
يهمهم، فهم يعتقدون أن ذلك يعد
انتهاكًا لحقوقهم،
لكن القضية الأساسية هي أن
الحجاب اليوم في الجمهورية الإسلامية هو قانون،
وعندما تصبح قضية ما جزءًا من
القانون، يجب على الجميع الالتزام بالقانون،
لذا فهو قانون.  نفس الشيء في جميع أنحاء العالم،
والآن
فيما يتعلق بالالتزام بالقوانين
في الواقع، فإن الأمريكيين وبعض
الدول الأوروبية يسعون فقط إلى
إحداث وضع ثنائي القطب في مجتمعنا،
لذا فهم يمارسون عملهم بهذه
الطريقة، وكانوا دائمًا يعتقدون أن إيران هي واحدة
من تلك الدول.  المجتمعات التي يمكن أن
تخلق فيها قطبين متعارضين مختلفين
حيث تتعارض قضايا المرأة والجنس
مع الحجاب، لكن
كن مطمئنًا أنه من خلال استخدام
هذه الأدوات لن ينجحوا، فإن
شعب إيران المستنير هم
أهل الإيمان، هم أناس روحيون و
إنهم يدركون بعمق أن الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية وثلاث
دول أوروبية لا تهتم بحقوقهم. إن
حجابهم الخاص
باحترام المرأة موجود منذ
مئات ومئات السنين في إيران،
وهو ليس تطورًا لاحظناه
في العقود القليلة الماضية.